Republicans in Wyoming want to phase out
the sale of new electric vehicles in
order to protect fossil fuels and indeed
many of the few jobs in Wyoming has a
low population many of the few jobs in
Wyoming are fossil fuel type States
um fossil fuel type jobs rather but this
is absolutely insane electric vehicles
are dramatically more efficient when it
comes to use of energy they have no
tailpipe emissions yes we have to figure
out some of the conflict minerals and
elements that are used for Batteries
we've got to figure out what to do with
the spent batteries that is being
figured out but until we get to the next
thing at least for now electrical
vehicle electric vehicles are the
logical step to get off of gas powered
vehicles and then there will be
something else coming behind it but
Banning the sale of electric vehicles
give me a break guys